Hello everyone. Welcome to this decoding
race series. So happy to have you here.
My name is Rachel [inaudible] and I'm
the project manager for race at Google
race that Google is a new comprehensive
effort across Google to organize around
racial justice issues.
Um, but more importantly,
this started back in 2013 after the
verdict of Trayvon Martin came out and a
group of BG enters, organize and
did a Hoodie march around campus.
And that's when we really started
grappling with race issues.
So I just want to take a moment to
honor one of our panelists, Sabrina,
for her sacrifice to get us to this point
where we could have a packed out room
and have race dialogues that
everyone wants to participate in.
And now I'm going to pass it along to
Felicia who's going to tell you she leaves
are decoding race series and she's going
to tell you a little bit more about
what you can expect from this talk.
Hey everyone.
Um,
first thank you so much for Rachel's
leadership and getting us to this point.
I started in January as the head
of black community engagement.
And I'm so very proud of our
company, uh, here at Google,
being willing to have open and
constructive conversations on race.
I think it's a huge step forward and
it's no secret that in our country,
racial tensions are high.
And so we want him to have a,
or do our part here at Google to have
those conversations again constructively
with external leaders.
And so just thank you for being here.
This is the third of a series
of conversations happening. Uh,
so we're so glad that we could do this
in San Francisco and be sure to join us
also in mountain view. Uh, December
12th for can computers be racist,
but today is about deconstructing race.
And so again,
we want to make sure that we are in
a room where we can be open, honest,
constructive with each
other. Uh, so we definitely,
definitely look forward to a
conversation, but also an exchange, uh,
at the end of this program. So thank
you so much. Without further ado,
I want to bring to the stage
Michael Skolnik. Michael A,
we contracted a to help us lead
the decoding race series. Uh,
he's done tremendous work already,
but even before his partnership
with Google on this,
he political advocacy, uh, for Russell
Simmons who we both worked for for years.
He's a national leader and activist in
his own right and we're so proud to have
him here as a strong supporter
and partner. So welcome Michael
[inaudible]
over here.
I want to thank the panelists.
These are all personal
dear friends of mine,
other flown from other country to be here.
Uh,
and our leaders are heroes and sheroes.
Um,
I sit on the board of the
Trayvon Martin Foundation,
so Sabrina and I work
very closely together. Um,
but so thank you all for taking
time out of your schedule,
especially during this
time, uh, to come here. Uh,
I would say think very briefly because I
know we want to hear from these amazing
people, uh, today. Um, the
day after the election, this,
this event was planned
way prior to thinking,
what would the outcome of the election
going to be? So there's no, um,
there was no quick maneuvering to
get this thing to happen today. Um,
this had been planned for a few months
now, but the day after the election,
I got a lot of phone calls from,
from friends or text messages and
emails from friends and family. Like,
what do we do? Um, from all
folks who voted for Trump,
folks who voted for Hillary,
what do we do?
And what I recommended to people to do
was to get together and have dinners in
their homes and just bring together
your family and your friends and your
colleagues. I invited 20 over
to my home on Wednesday night,
85 showed up. Uh, the
next night I invited 30,
90 showed up. So it's
no surprise Felicia, ah,
that best room was packed because I
think people want to get together in
community and have conversation.
But this is one of many. Uh,
so I would end by saying I am here
to be of service to you as Googlers.
We do have one coming up, uh, at mountain
view on the 12th. We have, I believe,
seven more after that are around the
country and around the world. Um, these,
uh, amazing people were folks
who are called on first. Uh,
but we have other folks we
want to call on after this.
So if there are people who you want
to come speak at your campuses,
across the country and across the world,
please let folks at Google know, um,
that you want them to come and
which we're taking, you know,
recommendations you want to bring the
best and the brightest minds we have in
this country and around
the world on this issue.
So please offer suggestions after
you hear this conversation today.
So this series really means something
to you. So without further ado,
I'm going to pass it off to my dear
friend, Michaela, Angela Davis,
who will lead the discussion today.
Thank you.
[inaudible]
Michael, thank you for setting, um,
setting the stage of this
as a conversation and, um,
I don't do panels. I don't
do keynotes. It's too real.
Like it's too real right now to not want
to make the effort to like really have
real talk. Where's my
sister? Felicia. Okay.
Don't get it twisted just
because he looks that years
girlfriend has been in the trenches
and I love you and there is no
mistake that it was sisters that put
this together because that's what we do.
So, uh, I appreciate it.
And on that note, I think it's first.
How y'all doing? No, I mean
real talk. How are you doing?
I I
there is um,
is very difficult to talk about something
as complicated and triggering as race
without particularly today
without checking in with
our humanity and a lot for a
lot of people they are rocked and terror
and traumatized and terrorize and it is
real. I haven't, you know,
I was talking to Felicia,
I have a 92 year old grandmother who
was a refugee from Jim crow south.
She was in World War Two.
She saw the assassination of Martin Luther
King and she told me my mother is the
worst thing that happened in her lifetime.
That's her.
For some people this is like, this
is the, this is the American dream.
We are having such a range of feelings,
like real ass feelings that
I d I just don't want to put,
I don't want to start this conversation
pretending that now we're just going,
we're going to solve race today at Google.
Right. But that we are um, that we,
that we ground this in our humanity and
in the ways that we can because I am
struggling.
I am radically revisiting
a lot of my relationships,
a lot of my projects, a lot
of my platforms. I am side,
I in so many people right now
when the numbers came out,
I'm going to just be honest.
I, I just, so I have to,
I want to be honest so we
can grow because they, we,
we can't be,
we can't shape shift around issues if
our intention is to understand each other
because sometimes it is more important
for I think for us to feel understood
than to be loved. Like I, you don't
have to like me and love me today,
but hopefully we walk away a
little bit more understanding.
So I just want to set that as my
attention today in this conversation is to
have, um, some honesty and get to
some understanding and understanding,
always leads to solution.
I think you look so familiar.
Yes. Hi. Anyway, so
it was just feeling your
editor. So, um, so I,
so instead of doing like
formal bio's, I'd love for, um,
and we'll start with you Jose.
First.
How are you feeling and how
do you identify yourself?
Like who are you as you
get to define yourself?
Um, I am a product of the bay
area, so this is where I'm from.
This is where I grew up. I grew up in
mountain view before Google got there,
okay.
To score at San Francisco state and lived
in Valencia and 17 when a studio was
$800.
So that's the first thing I would say.
Um,
but identity wise,
and I think identity is the
thread that ties it all together.
So I'm the Asian looking person
with a Hispanic name who's gay,
who was undocumented,
who majored in African American
studies at San Francisco State.
So that's my identity. What do you do? Um,
and then two years ago I made a
documentary for MTV called white people.
And I did that because I was really struck
after coming out as undocumented five
years ago, meeting so many young
white people across the country,
the millennial tolerant, diverse way
white millennials across the country.
I was struck that many of them
didn't know where they came from.
I mean in some ways immigration,
Angela Davis says it's like the link to
all of this because where we come from
and how we got here forcibly, right?
The African American slave experience,
right. Forced like nation, not forced
migration, whatever that is. Right.
And all struck at how many young white
people we interviewed just didn't know
where they were from him. And then
I started thinking, wait a second.
So how do you ask me where
I'm from and how I got here.
If you don't know how you got here,
like white is not a country, right?
And we have an organization called
define american.com and the whole job is
actually who were,
as everybody's doing Mikaila,
like going through like how do we talk
about our work in this new atmosphere and
what we came up with and crazy seven
hour meeting the other day is this idea
that we're actually trying to do
is tell America's whole story.
The story that has never really
been told like here in the valley.
And having grown up here and having
a lot of friends who, you know,
work in the tech industry, we like
to say that immigrants built America.
The moment we say that we are leaving
behind leaving off two groups of people,
maybe of Americans and black people,
right?
Like that is how do we tell America's
whole story in that way? Um,
one last thing about my feeling,
my feeling right now is as you know,
undocumented immigrants,
people like me have been at
the heart of this campaign. Um,
I would argue that Donald Trump was very
smart in making integration a central
part of his campaign because most
people don't know what that is, right?
People here, no h one B visa,
you know, Dream Act maybe.
But for the most part I spent,
I visited 48 states and done like 850
events like this in the past five years.
Most Americans don't know what that is,
right?
And he was able to kind of use that as
a central part of the campaign and to
blame people.
Americans are struggling,
every American is struggling and they
want someone to blame and they think it's
us. And I wonder what happens
when he, he becomes president.
President takes the lighthouse right now,
you know there are 700,000
young people who are,
who came to this country as children
illegally whose names, addresses,
phone numbers have been
given to the government that
Donald Trump is going to be
in charge of.
And I'm just finding out that some of
those young people are actually Googlers
who have that. So what are y'all going
to do when he starts rounding them up?
What are you going to do?
Right, and what the showing up
for each other. Me and
I loved that. The panel,
this is the versus it is
because I think representation,
like what do we all going to
do to show up for each other?
I think for me it's something
I'm really grappling with.
Um, I'm Krista Alonzo, I'm
a standup comic and, uh,
I feel
I feel broken.
Um,
I've been doing standup for 13 years.
I have traveled the country on the
road in a rental car by myself.
And, uh, I always felt
American. I was born in,
in Texas.
Um,
it wasn't till I started traveling by
myself that I realized how different the
country was. And, um,
I remember the first time I was, I wasn't
allowed to check into a hotel room,
which was in 2013.
And I was shocked and that's when it kind
of realized that I realized that life
was different outside of my bubble
when I went into the real country,
you know?
And,
and then I started realizing that I was
terrified of my life because I was put
in situations that were very
uncomfortable and I felt my God,
if I feel like that,
how many others don't feel like that.
It got to the point where I, um, I
used to do the Walmart test and a,
I would go into small towns and I go
to Walmart and if I saw that they had
Latino products,
I felt safe.
And if I didn't see the Latino products,
I wouldn't stay there
because I was scared.
Wait, let that settle in for a
second. Y'All feel that for a minute.
Particularly people that,
cause you know,
there are a lot of people in
here that could, maybe it's not,
they're looking for Latino, um, products,
but they have something similar,
right? If there's not a Martin
Luther King Boulevard maybe,
but settle into this, and this is for
the people of Whiteness in the room.
Particularly,
just imagine like
you're,
you're probably doing your own Google
search in your mind and there is nothing
like that, right? So just let that settle.
There's nothing in it,
in your database that goes,
let me check to see if I feel safe because
of my actual identity in this space.
Okay. So just, okay.
Um, I think that for me, uh,
this election has been a
life changing for me because
being completely honest, that's it.
That's how we got, um, I realized that,
uh,
I was actually seen as illegal too,
a lot of people because of my skin color.
And that's when I realized
that the term illegal,
not white because you think
how many immigrants from
European countries can come
in here and nobody asks them,
Hey, where are your papers?
Because their skin color dictates that
they belong here to potential first.
Like I'm coming to that
soon to be first lady. Yes,
absolutely.
So for me,
when I feel like that and I was born
here and I belong here and I don't feel
like I belong here, my God, how
does that make everybody else feel?
And for me,
I think I want to talk about it because
I think the most important thing that we
have to do is listen and we
need to accept our truths.
We can't negate and say, that
didn't happen to you. It did happen.
That's why you said it,
and I think that's how we change things.
To actually take everything
that we say as truth,
process it and say,
you know what?
I might be part of the problem and that's
how we learn to accept that maybe we
don't have our eyes completely open
and maybe understand that I'm at fault.
It's something. Maybe there's
something, I don't know.
I'm broken.
I did a panel last week with the Lotus
[inaudible] who fought for farm workers,
farm workers union.
I was crying nonstop after the election
and I walked into the room to meet her
and we've known each other for years.
She's like, why are you crying like this?
This election broke me.
She said country felt like
that when Nixon got elected.
They let me tell you about how it felt
and to hear those emotions that you don't
read them books. It took
it to own life. She,
she was standing next to Bobby Kennedy
when he was assassinated and she
describes hope dying in front of her face.
And when she talks about it,
I realized that this is the first
setback I've been through personally.
And that's why I'm so affected by it.
But when you see her,
you realize we're going to get through
this. Yeah, it's going to be hard,
but we're going to get through this.
And sometimes you need to hear the
history of somebody else to accept it and
process it.
So it's a perfect
Sabrina because when you
talk about people going
through it and what,
what is difficult and what
is pain and who, you know,
we often get into pain Olympics and
my pain and I couldn't see my cat and
no real talk. And also who, how people,
what people can stand through. And
you know, we, we opened this by, um,
I think that you inspired
this and Sabrina,
I am just indulge me for a
second because I love you.
I saw it. I loved you before I met you.
I saw you stand one. What does that mean?
Yeah.
You started a different kind of activism
for me because my entry point to
Humana,
I'm just going to be real.
My entry point to humanity
is through black women.
That is my on ramp into most things.
That's my,
you know how I start?
So when Trayvon was murdered,
I look where there was a lone black woman
standing with microphones and met you
had buried your boy.
The hardest thing that anybody who is it,
you know in your personal life,
if you are a parent in this room,
you know what I just said?
Okay,
you did that and you still stood and you
still created a moot the mothers of the
movement. Be Clear.
We're in this election.
You all were on the front grounds. You
all, you all were in towns, in churches,
in beauty shops.
You had every,
you had every reason to be broken
in bitter. How the Valley Brogan,
you buried your baby that never goes away
and still you were able to see how you
could help move this
country forward. Ew. Ew.
Ew. Trayvon is our Emmett till.
We know that. We know this,
the black lives matter started
okay
as a rallying cry for people to try to,
to,
to heal around what happened to
Trayvon because he was our son.
He is our son and if he is our
son then you are sister forever.
So thank you.
And why I think it's really,
really important for you to be in any
room is because we do look at life through
our own sets of disappointments and is
hard to do that with juices like you,
like really like how and and
and so how are you feeling?
And also I just sometimes get tired just
to be real real of we will make this
through this.
We're going to get up again.
Like there are times like I
don't want to live my life.
How much pain can we go through?
How much can we take?
And often people in the margins, that's,
I mean of course it's what we do.
Do we go to church, we got to our spirit,
we go to our flow, we go to each other.
But at some point when do we stop
getting knocked down? That's,
that's how I am today.
I might change,
but there are times that we
know we have to tell each other.
We won't be all right.
But sometimes it's like dance,
stop knocking us down.
Okay.
So,
oh,
and how do you identify who are you?
Before I was
Sabrina Fulton. Now I am Trayvon
Martin's mother. That's my name.
Trayvon Martin's mother.
And people even call me Ms. Martin,
which I have not been Ms. Martin and
many years cause I did divorce. I am.
And what I can't understand for the life
of me is how everybody can go through a
divorce and they don't
even see their exes.
But every time I turn around,
my ex is right here. And so
let me start off by saying my conversation
to you and what I have to say is not
polished,
is not filtered.
I may not say the right things
all the time, but it's how I feel.
Um,
when this happened,
I had a normal life,
you know,
uh, one house, one car,
two kids, Everage life. You know,
I was a government employee
working for the housing agency, um,
to try to assist low income residents.
Um, just normal life. I mean,
I had to save money to
take my kids on vacations.
I would go to work,
complain and keep looking at the
watch to this time to go home. I mean,
just an average things,
you know,
come home from work and asked my kids,
why didn't you take out the garbage?
Did you do your homework, cut your
hair, something, clean your room. Just,
just every day,
average things.
And I don't know how for the life of me,
my life got interrupted.
Okay.
So I constantly picked,
tell people however tie am because
this could have happened to anybody.
Average, average, average.
I want to continue to say that
to myself because I had a,
my family is very tight knit.
I have a very close family.
I have really good friends. I
have a strong church. I mean,
I think I did all the right things.
Okay.
And this happens to my son.
So it went from having a
decent average lifestyle. Um,
I'm from Miami, Florida. So
this looks like Miami and here,
you know, it's a mixture of everything.
It's not just African Americans,
it's everything is,
it's, it's Puerto Ricans,
it's kill Benz's Bahamians is Haitians,
Jamaicans is Colombian.
I mean everything. We have
everybody there. And, um,
I just don't understand for the life of
me how an average person paid my taxes.
I'm a citizen. I paid my taxes, you
know, I to work, I saved my money.
I did whatever I needed to do to take
care of my household and my kids and to
get rid of my ex husband.
Okay.
So on a,
on a serious note,
I went from a very average
life to a broken life
and then it continued to break.
So not only did I know or I found out
my 17 year old son had been shot and
killed and not just shut in Keel because
I don't believe everything that was
told to me by the Sanford
Police Department and by
the person that killed my
son. I just don't, and
you wouldn't either. Um,
but it was a part of me that said that
I was never going to San Fran again
and that I was just going to try to pick
up the pieces to my life and move on.
But that never happened
because the mother in me,
even though my son was to seize the
mother and me came up and stood up because
my son was shot down. So let,
let me just say that again.
When my son was shot down,
I stood up.
You never heard Trayvon Martin's
name before February 26 2012
so it'll bring out some things in you
and they can bring us some negative and
you went and bring out
some positive in you.
So don't think for one second that was
not negative thoughts in my mind there
were,
but I chose not to act on those
negative things and I chose to try to do
something positive to you.
Well,
what had happened to my son and just
the play on terms and just the play on
words.
Beyonce had a video out there,
you know that remember name?
Yeah,
lemonade
is when you're tying something
sour into something sweet.
And so that was something that was very
important to me because I didn't want to
live the rest of my life better because
it would have taken two lives instead of
one,
not only what Trayvon be deceased,
but I would be here on earth decease
and I had another son to live for.
I had my whole life to
live for and I decided,
I made up my own mind with
my broken pieces that were
on the floor that I wanted
to do something positive to help this
country because this country did not see
just how broken it was.
This country is broken.
We have to say that we have
to come to terms with it.
What is going on now is a reality show.
There's a show in is
happening to us and real life.
Well we have to say it,
a lot of people don't feel
like the justice system is
broken until you have a 17
year old son that's killed and you know
the exact person that shot and killed
him.
But because of a technicality,
because of the laws and
how the laws are applied,
the person walked free
and not just walk free,
but continued to do things
to antagonize the situation.
Like sell a gun.
Really,
really?
You mean to tell me the gun
that stopped my 17 year old.
You have people bidding on it.
So by it,
think about that for a second.
I know we're all walking around
here with the heart. What?
Some people are heartless,
some people are actually heartless.
But what I decided to do is I refuse
to let somebody else's ideas and
suggestions and comments
determine who I am.
And so a lot of people tell me how strong
I am. It's not because I want to be,
it's because I have to do this for my son,
for my son that's in heaven
and my son is here on earth.
I don't have a choice.
This is my new life,
this is who I am and I will
continue to fight for all children.
And two, I rest in peace.
And so it does not matter.
When I hear a story on the news and it
talks about a six year old that had been
drowned in a pool or
got in a car accident,
I don't care the color
of that child's skin,
it does not matter and we have to get to
that space where it does not matter if
it's your six year old brother
or your six year old son.
It does not matter the color of his skin
because I can sit here right now before
you and there are a lot
of things I can take off
my jacket, my blouse, my pants, my shoes,
but I cannot remove the color of my skin
nor do I want to because it's Hawaii.
I am
[inaudible].
Whenever I hear that,
when people say that the system is broken,
the country's broken.
I hear no,
I think the system is working and the,
I think that there are tons of,
we don't really acknowledge that we are
living in a post genocidal country at a
post. Like we started off with
stolen land and stolen labor. Yup,
that's true. The history.
Right? So perhaps,
and I'm not even here yet,
this is just a philosophical,
like I'm just working it out with y'all.
Perhaps we are not broken.
Perhaps we're getting closer to being
fixed because we started off with genocide
and slavery. Let's be clear. Yup. Right?
So how does even a post genocidal country
say that they were ever whole and how
does the justice system that was designed
to contain and you know most most
people,
so,
so hopefully I'll get there in my heart
that maybe sometimes healing and being
scars feel the same when they are
healing and when they are happening.
And so perhaps this pain
that we're experiencing isn't
the breaking it breaking
of America.
It may be the actual unifying of it
because now some people can actually feel,
this is the first time some of my white
liberal friends aren't life fucked up.
They're like,
oh my God,
what you've been saying is real.
Oh my God. You know, it's
not theory. It's real.
There's possibility in this moment y'all,
even though we're broken,
we're crying because this doesn't
happen to everybody. Sabrina list,
you know this, I've never heard
of white colleagues say, Oh,
I'm afraid my child might
not come home from school.
Okay?
And I,
I didn't see the fathers of Sandy Hook
get together march across the country and
talk about gun reform.
You did not have to do this.
There are people whose babies have been
killed by gun violence and they think,
oh my God,
that was a phenomenon,
a horrible phenomenon
that my young white child
got shot four black families.
Okay?
For Latino families, there are people,
there are mass graves at the border.
We don't even know your names.
They are Latino people being lynched.
We don't know their names.
So this doesn't happen to everybody.
Let's just be clear about that.
Let's be honest. You,
you are extraordinary,
okay?
[inaudible]
are you feeling and how do you define,
um, I'm feeling incredible amount of
dissonance. That's going to be the word.
I don't have a feeling word right now,
isn't it? Says where I'm, where I'm at.
And I think to your point of how do we,
when we're shifting from something
soured, it's something sweet. Uh,
moving to lemonade. It makes me think
alchemy, it makes me think of the process.
What does it take for a piece
of coal to become a diamond?
And it's an incredible amount of pressure
that's put on it and you have to face
face it if you're going to
actually Walter, that I want
to borrow from Juno Diaz.
I read the New Yorker article of artists
and I think this is such an important
time for people who are artists,
creatives,
writers to help us make
sense of the chaos,
make the chaos coherent is sort of
where we're at. And I think, um,
election night and the next morning I
reached out to one of my dissertation
advisors John Diamond and was like,
I don't understand.
I feel like I re reword it to like a
five year old. And it was like, you know,
like someone makes sense of this for me.
And one thing that I thought was
really useful about the way Juno Diaz
characterize it is he saying that we
are grappling with a level of rejection
that's at a macro level. I think
if you're black, if you're brown,
if you're Muslim,
if you're Lgbtq,
if you're a woman who didn't
vote for Trump, um, you're,
you're in a place of flow in a macro level
of rejection and incredible amount of
fear.
The vulnerability that I think most
many people have walked around with.
But I feel like it's heightened now. I've
been looking at the SPLC count of, uh,
incidents of harassment.
Yeah,
I think there are over 400 since
election night has been announced.
And just literally for me,
I have to like,
there's a prayer before I exited my door
of like lawyer wherever I encountered a
day, just, just like
cover me on the train.
There was a video of that
was put out or women on bark,
I think she was from Algeria and she
was recording a woman on Barton who's
telling her,
how are you going to be deported?
It Trump's going to send you out of here.
Um,
I used to be an elementary school
teacher and people who are teaching in
classrooms, um, that are in my network,
uh, where kids are yelling, you know,
build a wall to Latino kids
sitting in the classrooms. Um,
my dad who's immigrated from Nigeria sent
me a video yesterday morning of Trump
actually talking about not allowing
west African immigrants to come into the
country. Um, so I, I think
there's a level of fear.
There's a level of rejection
as a level of vulnerability.
And I see like we're in
morning and a lot of ways,
and I think that we're mourning this
experimental idea of democracy because I
think America is unique from other
countries in the sense that it's not to
roadshow and multiethnic,
multiple religions.
I'm all in one space and it does have a
history of genocide and the history of
involuntary immigration, um,
for, for, um, African peoples.
But I would say for the way that America
has pursued it's foreign interest,
what suggested even other people who
are immigrating here voluntarily,
you may not necessarily be
so volunteering. Right. Um,
so, um, I think there's
a level of despair.
I think what's been challenged is
our vision for this country, I think,
and the ideals that have been held up.
So most of us have been sold a story
since birth about what America is about
democracy.
And a lot of us who identify that people
identify white had been sold a real
good story about the history and a
lot of things have been left out.
A lot of things have been sugar coated.
Um,
and I think that a lot of people who
are in who are now just coming into this
and waking up like, oh my gosh,
I didn't even know this was real.
I think it says a lot about the bubble
and you've grown up in and what's the
implications of segregation?
The implications of like
the choices I've made.
The New People here can wake up and turn
on the television and see only people
who look like them on the TV.
They can go to any magazine rack and
the hundred most influential people all
look like them. The most beautiful
people in. We're always looked like that.
And they can go to their church,
they can go to the synagogue,
they can go to a funeral.
And it's everybody who looks like them,
the toys that they buy for their kids,
the media that they consume
in terms of entertainment.
Like sometimes I literally have
watched television and I'm just,
I'm gonna go through each station to
see if I can just find one black person,
like without going to be,
if I do find us,
like how are we being characterized?
Is there some variation or does it
fit the stereotypical narrative?
So I think I'm in a place of dissonance
and I'm in a place of, of mourning,
like deep mourning internally. And, um,
I have to think about my grandfather.
He was born in 1911 in Texas
and when I was very young,
I was still at his feet and
just stare at his hands.
And he had these hands that were full of
wrinkles and scars and tears and Marx.
And he had been working in cotton
fields since he was seven years old.
His mother was half native American,
half African American and wasn't slaved.
And I remember I would,
I don't know why,
but his hands just carried
the story of his family.
And what does it mean to pick cotton?
What does it mean to start doing that?
A seven years old? What does it
mean to have to drop out of school?
Because your older brothers were fighting
in a war then when in a country they
weren't citizens of, um, and,
and what it meant to actually
keep going back despite that.
And he adopted my mom. I'm at six months
old. We didn't have any kids of his own.
And I sit with that right now of what it
meant for him to survive 1911 until he
passed.
And then like in the late nineties,
and I think about Dave Chappelle when he
talked about what it meant to be alive,
um,
through that time.
Like we just think about the depression
in and of itself would admit to survive
that if we think about the 1960s a number
of black people who were killed from
like 1960 to 1969 in a very public forum.
I can't even imagine this psychic
violence that, that, that creates.
And those were all people who were, who
were activists, who were organizers,
who were putting themselves on the line.
And what does it mean now
for us to witness digitize
killings of black and Brown
people, native American people
on the Internet, on Facebook,
and the psychic violence
that creates for us. Um,
and then to have the same electorate that
supported Obama twice with elect Trump
now or select, I don't know if it was
elect yet, there's a popular vote,
didn't really count this time.
Um,
so I'm in a place of extreme dissonance
and incredible amount of, of morning.
Um, but I'm, I'm also, I'll
get to the hopeful place and,
and like less work and less fight,
but right now I want to sit in the
dissonance and I want to say it with the
morning.
Thank you that that's honest. I'm sorry.
This is really how this had to go today.
You know,
like we had to,
we couldn't get it all academic
about but we um, but we,
but we do want to be in conversation
so it would be great too to shift to,
to you. Um, oh great. Okay.
India.
Oh Great.
I'm going to read a question of,
of our door.
You were Googlers all over
the world. Um, are, um,
asking questions. Yes. I'm
not in the frame. I'm sorry.
Okay, here we go. All right.
Okay.
So we actually have someone from India
asking this question we hear a lot about,
so he's asking for a comment.
We hear a lot about black and Hispanic
experience experiences and related
interventions,
but not much about how other races
experience the multicultural workplace.
For example, Asians,
Indians who are also agents,
etc. So any comments on that?
Uh, have a lot to say about
this freight to see it here.
But here it goes back to
what Miguel is saying.
I actually think we are where we are
because our conversations are far too
comfortable and simplistic. We've had each
other in the back. We think we're down.
We think we know what's happening,
all of that. Before I say what I say,
I think I also from a, I've been just
doing a lot of reading is grounding me,
but I've been thinking that in some ways
11 nine that is when Donald Trump got
elected. It's in many ways the
culmination of nine 11 right?
After nine 11 we,
after we were terrorists as a country,
we started terrorizing each other,
right?
We sort of terrorizing each other
like the other and all of us.
I have to say that having traveled
the country like the other,
now many people feel are working
class white people. Right?
I can't tell you how many times I've
interviewed working class white people who
feel that they're not welcoming
their own country and I'm like, Yo,
you built this. What are you talking
about? Right. So that conversation,
so I'm going to name one
statistic that I think is crucial.
In the next 50 years in America,
88% of the total population growth is
going to come from Latinos and Asians.
88% at a time when the black lives matter
movement that you had sparked should
forever be central.
Because how we deal with anti blackness
and the Latino and the Asian community
in the Arab community is important.
And at a time when white people
are an emerging racial minority,
which is already the case in high schools
all across America and grade schools
in high schools across America.
Now it's fascinating whenever we talk
about race and identity that Asian people
who are now the fastest growing
racial and immigrant group,
72% of all Asian adults
in America are immigrants.
We are more immigrants than
Latinos are immigrants.
And yet we are just kind of
invisible in our, you know,
rice noodles, and I hate to
say it out, I'm just, you know,
I don't want to stereotype this,
but if you think about it,
the Asian community as it is, is a huge
community with different languages,
different cultures. We don't
all speak Spanish, you know,
the only thing that I've got that has
really organized Asian people in the past
two years was a letter
those edited on Google docs.
And I don't know if you remember this,
when Asian people in Twitter
started getting together
after Philando Casteel and
wrote an open letter to their families
about why they stand up for black lives.
And I remember going into the letter, I'm
like, I'm a journalist, I can copy edit.
So I'm copy editing the letter.
And at one point on Google doc,
this amazing Google doc thing,
there was like 200 of us.
Do you think Jose Mpas,
I mean just in the world of
engineering or safety standards,
often things are built because of some
kind of horror or tragedy or you know,
you know what I mean?
And so because we don't have a Trayvon
Martin to or or a build a wall,
kill them all kind of thing too to attach
to the Latino community or you know,
what are we seeing Muslims
being terrorized so we can
make so people emotionally
get involved.
Do you think that that has something
and I think because in this country to
be American has always been to be white,
white miss was constructed
to say you're not black.
And now that the most of the countries,
Latino and Asian, how we pass us white.
Like sometimes I wonder within my own
Asian friends and colleagues like how many
of us actually think were white
or better than white, right?
Like we're not even a part of that
conversation. And now that Asian people,
and I'm saying this is an uh,
someone who is undocumented
and has been doing this work,
it's been really lonely. How even in
the own, how in the Asian community,
this has been a silent,
for the most part silent issue.
The fastest growing undocumented
population are Asian immigrants.
One out of seven Koreans in this country
is undocumented. One out of seven. Right?
And so the fact that we have allowed
it to be racialized as a Latino Mexican
issue, right? We've allowed it. Right.
And what I struggle with is this
idea, now what do we do? Right?
Like there was a report that said that
apparently Asian people are now the most
affluent and educated
group of people in America,
yet civic involvement, like
what does citizenship, I was,
I gave this really
uncomfortable speech in Chicago.
The home of like a lot of Filipinos
make us a little bit. Yeah, so,
so it was like 300 Filipinos, you
know, and you know, I can't vote.
I've been here for 23 years
since I grew up amount of view,
but I'm here illegally so I don't
have any voting power. Right.
So I asked the audience, Hey, let me go,
here are American citizens like 90%
how many people are registered to vote?
Out of 300 people, maybe 10 and I'm like,
book the Lumpia down.
You know what we'll get is it's amazing.
I'm like,
are you freaking kidding me with this?
There is more to America than buying
an ice house and driving a Lexus and
earning the money so you can send
it home to the Philippines in boxes.
Like how are we going
to involve ourselves?
This is our home and the intersection
of race and immigration. Right?
The first group of people that
racially got excluded were Chinese.
The Chinese exclusion act in this country
with an in and giving me the American
citizenship rights until 1924 I would
argue that the black lives matter movement
is all about citizenship,
but it's way beyond papers a loss,
but it's about dignity.
So to me,
I actually think the question of
citizenship of how we earned that,
how many people here are American
citizens? Can you raise your hands?
Congratulations. I'm
so happy you are. Now.
The question though is what are you doing
to risk it and what have you done to
earn it and not to the people
who have always been marginalize,
right.
I would argue that I definition of
America for me are the people have always
been excluded from it
and have to fight for it.
All of us have done that in our capacity,
and I'm sorry,
just we're going to get
uncomfortable about this.
The conversation is really about
whiteness and how that is always central.
How it's always as if we always have
to explain who we are and how we got to
where we got.
I actually think we should start a
woman trying to explain why people,
how did you get to where you got
[inaudible].
Why, why do you think you're
the center of the world?
Why is it that when white people move,
it's manifest destiny,
it's the next frontier. It's
white man's burden. When we move,
it's a question of
legality and criminality.
How can my iPhone have more
migrant rights than I do?
Hmm.
I think that's an
essential question.
And all of us who are privileged,
you know, we are in San Francisco,
we are here like again,
the question is what are you
doing to risk your privilege?
How are you going to get them comfortable?
How are you going to get
out of your comfort zone?
How are you going to learn the
fullness of American history? Right?
And how are we going to advocate for us?
So I think that is kind of where I'm at.
And I feel like sometimes we,
you know,
dupont to Ella about shape
shifting. You know, like I always,
when I'm in front of Conservative
tea party Republicans,
like I was just at like last week I
have to go, okay, don't offend them.
Don't be the angry illegal
person. The smile, you know,
pronounce your words like Charlie rose.
Um,
and you know, I, I feel as if
my life and maybe Asian people,
because of our identity,
we were always so excluded,
always excluded that maybe because of
that we've internalized that exclusion,
but now we have to insist
on being included and we
have to insist on being too
[inaudible].
We're going to get a quick question.
Can I know, I know you can hold it.
Is there a question from the floor? I just
wanted to say thank you. First of all,
even the discussion was about race.
You asked everyone what their identity
was and that is really important to me
because what I consider myself,
my identity is not really race because
I feel other people don't look at me and
see an Indian split I've always grown up
is people look at me and see religion.
So identify myself as a
sick who is often mistaken.
For the first 15 years of my life,
people would call me a Buddhist and then
the last 15 years of side 11 a muscle
and that's fine. I don't mind being
mistaken, someone I would like it to be.
It makes me happy when
people recognize me,
but it's fine because I think it's
important to accept everyone who they are.
For me personally,
I don't mind if people mistake me for
someone else or some something else.
What I do want is people to accept
others for who they are just too.
They are whoever,
however they label themselves.
My question is how do we promote
just acceptance right now?
That's the biggest thing
which I think is dividing us.
Even if you feel some way or
spiel someone else's raw as,
and there's a lot of people who are
angry at like the people you were saying,
who are,
you know,
the poor white middle class who felt
marginalized and there's all people who
just didn't accept them.
How do we just promote
acceptance in general and
what's the best way to go about
doing that?
One of the things.
One of the things that I would say is
as a human race,
we really have to get back to the basics.
We really have to start
respecting one another.
Regardless of your education level,
you can't possibly look at someone
and tell if they're educated or not.
It's just so not important.
What's important is that they are a human
being and you should care about them
merely because they are regardless.
Nobody asks to be here.
You,
you didn't ask your parents to be born,
you didn't,
and so we have to make
the best of WHO's here.
I just have so much to say.
It's just hard for me
to put it into words,
but we have to get back to
the basics and that's respect.
It doesn't matter if, if I have
long hair, if I have short hair,
I had dreadlocks of my hair is nappy.
If my hair is blonde,
Brunette,
Brown hair,
it doesn't matter if I wear glasses or
don't wear glasses or I'm short, I'm tall,
whatever religion I am,
it does not matter.
Can you just for a second, look to
the person to your right and just say
hello.
When was the last time you
just said hello? How are you?
We have to get back to the basics.
I'm a firm believer and
that it does not matter.
All the things that
are put into our heads,
and I shouldn't say it by social
media and by the media, you know,
it's just so
those things are not important.
Hmm.
What's important is who's here,
what we're doing and how
we're going to move forward.
It does not matter your, your, your
nationality. It does not matter your race.
It does not matter your religion.
Everybody is a human being and
we should treat them as such.
Let's get back to the basics.
[inaudible]
well, why don't you go, I
want to get another question.
I know that that we're going to,
both of you can have ha prepared like
30 seconds. How do you want to respond?
But this is helping. We have to tell each
other stories. Okay, well how have you,
all of you can help us think about
how to move forward. Like how,
what frightens me is the level of
hatred that we have so much time,
so many hate crimes act.
And so instead of Hillary Clinton being
sad that she didn't win, how can we, um,
activate those people, President
Obama, Hilary Clinton to say,
how can we make a stand that those
ask are not going to be tolerated and
prosecuted to the highest level of
the existing law that we have now?
How can we stem the tide and
everyone who felt differently,
what can we do actively to make
that stop? Did, do you mind if I,
if I throw that to Michael,
but just some fair, no,
not to shock you, but just some various,
you know, because there's some very,
there's some places to go.
So if you can just kind of give a couple
of websites or places to go to be very
pragmatic about that.
Okay.
Very pragmatic. But I'm also
going to segue to on my own show,
I think some southern poverty
law center, right? Aclu,
which organizations that need help,
I'm going to give you support.
So go to the southern poverty law
center website and Slu on that specific
question on hate crimes.
We've seen 400 plus hate crimes since
the election of Donald Trump, uh,
reported in this country.
Um,
and that is what southern poverty law
center has seen in six months prior to
that. So 401 week, six months
prior and reported hate crimes. Um,
so sort of those two
organizations you can go,
if you could give resources your time,
your energy. I think he was a help.
Can I just say that? I think
that, uh, we talk about,
we're talking about race
and we also have to,
we have to talk about why Trump won one.
Yeah.
And I think this is the theory is that
for eight years there were white people
that felt like they weren't listened to.
They weren't paid attention to what they
felt disenfranchised to solution and
they decided to do something about
it. And it's, it's cute for me
that it's eight years
because people of color,
that's what we live our
entire lives based out of.
Our entire existence is based out
of being uncomfortable, feeling,
feeling left out.
And it's weird to think that so many of
them under the Obama administration felt
like that,
but that shows that there's a problem
because they didn't feel like they were
being listened to.
We feel like we haven't been listened to
and I know I haven't been listened to.
I know my people haven't been listened to.
I mean look,
we're the guy won on the
premise of building a wall
and I have people calling me
illegal and say awful things
to me everyday of my life now.
It's weird to think the,
the Midwest
felt like a person of color did for eight
years and they did something about it.
I think it's interesting that we're in
this room talking about hundreds of years
and we're still trying to catch
up in eight years. They got to,
they got to have their voice spoken and
here we are saying it's been hundreds of
years.
What do we do?
And it's weird to think that in order
to make any kind of advancement,
we really do.
We have to pay attention to what we're
saying because that's the only way that
we can move forward to make
each other feel like we matter.
We have to matter. That's I think
one of the most important steps.
What do we do? How do we fight?
How do we let her voice heard? Um,
except everybody for what they're saying,
even though you may not agree.
I think that in order
to make any progress,
we have to make the country
very uncomfortable for a
long time now until they
listen.
All right,
talk [inaudible] we all know every,
everybody these
tradition, they tell stories and
that's what you hear someone's story.
You can't unhear it.
And so I want to thank you for
giving us a space to share this.
Now everyone knows a little
bit more about somebody and um,
there's power,
there's power in and then it,
even though we're all tripping
and broken and feeling crazy,
I do feel there's a lot of smart people
in this room and there is opportunity in
tragedy always. Sabrina is
testimony to that, right?
So take care.
I think we need to take care of ourselves.
And everybody get their
10 sessions, but, um,
but feel like,
be available to the opera.
There are hundreds of thousands of young
people in the street that are letting
us know something that the future does it,
the future is not comfortable.
Right.
So I feel very encouraged by that if we're
seeing like all these youth uprisings
and they're very mixed. They
look like this room. So, um,
thank you so much. Thank you. Thank you.
[inaudible].